qu'est ce qui vous a plu vous la dent
dans l'idée dans le titre même de ce
film jeunesse parce que en tant que
comédienne comédiens vous êtes concerné
vous n'êtes pas par ce problème de la
jeunesse de l' envie de créer
j'aimerais bien retrouver ma jeunesse je
ne peux pas dire ouh là là la chose la
mieux
pourquoi ils appellent ça la jeunesse
soit 82 ans
à none of moscow news je sais que les
simples et jeunesse parce que moi je
joue dedans mais à part à part ça je ne
sais pas j'ai pas compris
est-ce que de temps en temps on penser
au film au dernier film que vous allez
faire au dernier film à tourner harry
keitel dans votre carrière
c'est la vérité
je n'ai même pas encore l'impression
d'avoir terminé celui-ci
est le film a été tourné aux états unis
et au mexique mais
j'ai avant tout un film sur l'américain
le film s'intéresse pas vraiment aux
cartels en fait les gens s'ils vont voir
un film pour voir un documentaire ou
apprendre des choses sur les cartels
mexicains on est relativement déçu c'est
un film qui s'intéresse aux victimes des
cartels et plus particulièrement aussi
la manière dont les américains bret pour
pourrait potentiellement le fantasme du
week-end intervenir face à des
revendeurs dans leurs frontières pour
résoudre le problème par la violence
à votre avis quel est l'événement ici au
festival de cannes qui a suscité le plus
de réactions sur les réseaux sociaux
depuis le début est ce que c'est la
venue de charlize theron et sean penn
est ce que c'est le décolleté de salma
hayek benicio denis peut-être une piste
c'est les les trois femmes se sont fait
refuser sans talent au jury
au thé cette rumeur
de cette rumeur que lui hier que pam
donc interdite de montée des marches
parce qu'elle n'avait pas de talons et
c'est vraiment incroyablement devant
tout ce qui s'est dit au festival devant
l'attitude de la jurée sophie marceau
sur les marches et c'est plus de 6000
tweed devant la cérémonie d'ouverture et
c'est quasi seize mille tweets oui on
est la pâte allons pas de film la rumeur
la polémique dix neuf mille tweets loin
devant alors on précise que les
organisateurs ont quand même démenti
depuis
en fait il ya deux tino ya tarantino et
sorrentino est le point commun le
dénominateur commun ce sont deux talents
géniaux
les touristes aux antilles la loi ont
vraiment pris pour une diesel ils sont
venus vous voir de matane et attendez
c'est franck gastambide que je vois sur
cette photo là et même antoine de caunes
louis borloo
alors tu as des déchets pour le titre et
c'est dans la toute première fois en
janvier à lille avec vers la salle non
écoute jeu c'était drôle de cultiver
cette espèce de pseudo ressemblance que
j'ai avec une d elles et oui c'est drôle
sur le tournage était vraiment habillée
comme ça et il y à il ya des gens en
thaïlande qui pensait vraiment que ces
visuels et qui sont venus faire les
frais avec moi ils ont dû être très
déçus chez eux en regardant la photo en
ce 8 mai à agir si vous trouvez que il
ressemble à vinh diesel
il est dehors alors oui quand je regarde
et je me disais oui eh bien c'est dit
évalue des maristes ces vidéos n'ont ni
carrefour because there is this very
zohra violet très faste et furieuse
pourquoi vous êtes loin derrière tout le
monde pas parce que là il vaut mieux que
ce soit les gens qui sont beaux ils sont
jeunes qui mangent des marches en même
temps le cinéma vous dois tellement que
vous répondre que la lumière temps en
temps oui la main pas besoin de la
lumière allumée rc ouvre le film
la mère vous tend les bras si je puis
dire
je vais pas y aller tout seul ou légale
et avec qui je vous en ferai le mecredi
coeur
on est dans le vif tous nos matches
oui
allez
eh
ben on le
sait l'histoire si mes informations sont
bonnes à un chasseur de têtes dans le
monde glamour des mannequins qui qui
rapatrient des belles femmes russes dans
les bras de riches de ligue arc tout à
fait autobiographique 6 et non pas du
tout c'est une fiction absolue mais un
film très
très spectaculaire
avec des plans magnifiques je trouve
qu'il ya un sens de l'image dans ce film
est en même temps un mystère une
intelligence il est bien dit alors bien
sûr d'autant plus qu'il ne l'est pas
tournée
m
oui
oh
tu ta